tous les deux précisé et avoue 5 est ce
que en fait dans cette dans ce contexte
comment tenir des élections crédibles en
fait et après juste une question à vous
monsieur le président dans le communiqué
des ministères des affaires étrangères
et de l'armée à l'issue du de plus deux
avec la russie cet après midi la france
met clairement en garde la russie sur
les conséquences graves de toutes
nouvelles atteintes éventuelles à
l'intégrité territoriale de l'ukraine
concrètement ça se traduirait par
quelles actions de la part de la france
merci
est ce que vous voulez dire un mot
alors la
réponse est claire le 24 décembre
en fait nous ne contrôlons pas la date
il ya un une haute commission nationale
électorale qui détermine les dates qui
maîtrise les dates et nous et que les
élections présidentielle et législatives
soit simultané
simultanéité
comme cela peut être on peut avoir l'une
des élections le 24 et l'autre le 25
mais bon c'est là le haut comme la haute
commission nationale des élections
libyenne qui déterminera les dates et la
façon dont cela se passera je voudrais
souligner que nous n'avons pas de
désaccord les questions législatives
sont du ressort du parlement il y a des
lois qui ont été votées il y a une haute
commission nationale électorale qui
travaillent et que nous soutiendrons et
si la commission parvient à organiser
les présidentielles et législatives le
24 décembre eh bien nous remettrons le
pouvoir à la première autorité élue et
c'est ce que nous avons tous les deux
réaffirmé et donc aignan aucun désaccord
sur le 24 décembre tous les libyens sont
d'accord pour dire que le 24 décembre il
y aura des élections
mais nous insistons sur un processus
électoral
l'athée câbles et des mesures et de
véritables la garantie qu'ils soient
acceptés par tous et c'est pour cette
raison que nous sommes aujourd'hui à
paris pour réaffirmer l'ensemble de ces
points je vous remercie
clarifiant puisque vous avez il
président une première qui affirment
tous deux vouloir la même chose après il
ya en effet des structures qui sont
mises en place la haute commission comme
ça a été rappelé il ya le rôle du
parlement qui est aussi important l'idée
est que justement tout converge je pense
que il ya trois acquis par rapport à ce
que vous avez évoqué important de cette
conférence la première c'est que pour la
première fois la libye la coprésider
avec la présence qui permet de telle
clarification du président et du premier
ministre la deuxième c'est qu'il ya eu
un engagement de l'un et l'autre sur le
processus la date du 24 décembre et le
respect si le processus est bien
inclusif avec d'observateurs
internationaux de constater le résultat
des élections
et le troisième point c'est qu'il ya eu
un soutien de la communauté
internationale unanime pour ce processus
sous supervision des nations unies et
avec des observateurs que nous avons
pour lesquelles nous avons tous évoqué
notre disponibilité pour en effet
fournir des observateurs former et aider
au bon déroulé donc je pense c'est un
acquis très important après aucun
d'entre nous ne peut se substituer à la
souveraineté libyenne que nous défendons
et donc au rôle que chacune des
institutions
aura à jouer dans les prochains jours et
les prochaines semaines
sur votre deuxième question
des ministres ont tenu une réunion et
ils ont réitéré à cet égard ce que
madame la chancelière cette 1er mai
c'est le président du conseil italien
moi même avons pu dire sur sur ce sujet
est en effet sur le respect des accords
de minsk du processus de normandie et de
l'importance de la question ukrainienne
je pense qu'il ait jamais opportun dans
ces moments là de faire de la politique
fiction madame la chancelière a eu
l'occasion
changer avec le président poutine hier
je n'échangerais dans les tout prochains
jours avec le président poutine sur
plusieurs sujets celui ci celui de la
biélorussie également je sais que le
président du conseil italien fera de
même donc nous continuons un travail
convergent sur ce sujet avec toujours le
même esprit qui est la sécurité la
stabilité de l'europe ce qui me permet
aussi de rassurer votre collègue italien
pour rendre ça est de dire que je
souscris à tout ce qu'a dit le président
du conseil draghi sur la convergence
entre nos vues important une vue
européenne sur ce dossier libyen tous
les trois je crois que nous arrivons au
terme de cette conférence de presse je
voulais remercier vraiment où les
coprésidents et coprésidente de cette
conférence est juste avoir deux mots
l'un pour remercier les nations unies et
tout particulièrement monsieur khoury
qui est fait un travail remarquable et
courageuse en leur nom sur le terrain
merci
présent au quotidien et redire ici
est vraiment redire ici à toutes les
libyennes et tous les libyens que notre
volonté est qu'il puisse exercer leur
souveraineté qu'ils aient le droit de
vote et le droit de vivre en paix en
sécurité
c'est cela le coeur de notre travail
merci beaucoup
[Musique]